buenos dias raúl los retos de la primera
ministra mirtha vásquez va a ser mejorar
las relaciones entre el gobierno de
pedro castillo y el parlamento reactivar
la economía que se ha visto estancada
debido a la crisis política y por si
esto fuera poco lidiar con la falta de
vacunas precisamente a la organización
panamericana de la salud ha señalado que
las vacunas que estaban comprometidas
para entregarse a este país a fin de año
no va a ser posible debido a que existen
retrasos con el mecanismo cobas facility
y además en las autoridades sanitarias
han revelado que la vacuna rusa de
sputnik v todavía no tiene un tiempo
estimado de llegada a esta nación
cantina francisco como quedan ahora
entonces las relaciones entre el ex
primer ministro guido metido y el
partido perú libre
bueno las relaciones entre pedro casio y
sus socios políticos no están del todo
buenas precisamente guido ha venido
retorna al congreso para reasumir su
cargo de legislador desde ahí junto con
sus compañeros de la bancada oficialista
no van a respaldar a este nuevo gabinete
y justamente la congresista de perú
libre silvana rolex considera que los
cambios realizados por el presidente
pedro castillos constituyen realmente un
suicidio político porque afirman que él
ha sucumbido a presiones de la derecha y
de los grupos económicos y afirma que
tarde o temprano el congreso que es
gobernado por la derecha lo someterá a
un proceso de impeachment o vacancia
presidencial